today MA oh okay Dee she caught up mmm
no dokgo it
hinto am i Ashtar sorry oh she knows hmm
I need a nanny
watashi wa mo kio - da e ma you made you
ah so so you've got them all
Kushina ah
Kalash gonna come back the colossi
what's poppin guys mmm a little bit sick
today but it's okay I got sick from
Montreal zombie okay
I'm not and they be shuffled uh-uh
come to you whatever but I'm okay now
just a little bit of cough you know in
case you care but yet today we are
moving as you can see my room is mostly
packed and now we hired some people to
move for us
so yeah I'll talk to you later I think I
might code later on today but for now
I'm just gonna move and I will show you
some footage from that
[Music]
I'm gonna take a little break ah almost
done packing it's pretty good
I'm just gonna gonna take a nap here
real quick all right peace out guys he's
nice knowing you bunk that but I think
it's time to go
[Music]
I mean Monsieur I've never felt that way
for anyone else I love you from the
bottom of my heart but it's time for me
to move on it's time for you to move on
to I love you
[Music]
I'll never forget you
I've been through you will always be my
favorite bedframe
we can replace you dirty dog alright
what's up guys so welcome to my new
place now I don't want to show you
everything yet because I want to keep it
as a surprise make another video about
it also I haven't decorated yet so I'm
gonna wait till I'm done but today we
are doing some coding we're going to
continue on on on our web app if you
haven't seen the first video which was
like some JavaScript title that I put
I'll put it in the link in the
description but you could check that out
first and then I'll continue doing that
web app today let's go oh yeah before I
start I just wanted to tell you that the
video that I'm putting here as a
template is that it's done by someone I
really admire his name is Jung and he
makes awesome cinematography videos and
yeah I just want to shout him out go
check his channel a link in the
description below he makes amazing
videos and I aspire to become like him
yeah check them out alright cool so
let's start let's pull up the stuff that
I had before ok cool so so what I want
to do now is I want to add socket IO
because that's how I'm going to
communicate with the server so what I'm
gonna do I'm just gonna go socket IO now
socket IO is pretty cool it's basically
like a like a library that
wraps around the WebSocket technology if
you don't know what WebSockets are it's
basically just a ongoing TCP connection
from the client and the server like
instead of HTTP where it has to open a
whole TCP connection every time it sends
a request this one keeps the TCP
connection and it will stand back and
forth so basically the advantage of that
is that the server can push information
rather than the client having to request
information from the server every time
so instead of doing a polling mechanism
the server can just push information to
the client so if you don't know what TCP
is don't worry about it you'll learn in
at school it's like a basic Network
thing so yeah all right let's see okay
now the first thing I'll do read a
little bit of docs okay
so first of all gotta install socket IO
okay let's copy this done all right
kids check it out saved it in package
our JSON let's see socket all right cool
I have it the version 2.0 that's good so
I have to change the server code a
little bit because right now it's just
Express and basically I have to add
socket IO so let me do that real quick
do a little bit of a change here oops
okay take this off and then okay perfect
oops outside this perfect and now I
gotta add the add the IO
which is the library but the HTTP
library mm-hmm
ok wait let me just copy this alright
now we are going to add the same thing
but the front end I'm gonna have to
download the socket IO javascript file
oh ok finally I found the down render it
is ok cool so let's see how we do the
front-end and let me read this did you
do oh there it is ok alright so another
thing for you guys for some people who
are like oh my god man you keep
searching up [ __ ] oh my god dude what
you know can't you don't you know about
hard and stuff like that yes I just want
to tell you if you don't like me
searching things because I'm just trying
to be realistic here
you know I just want to show you how I
code you know I might not be the best
holder so if you don't like it you can
go find another youtuber that would
teach you WebSockets so just saying
alright anyways so I gotta copy this
code snippet we're gonna copy this code
snippet add it to the front end alright
Frank code done that's cool so we got
WebSockets on dope so now I am just
going to use that WebSocket and put
events on the clicking on the play
clicking on the pause and clicking on
the timeline so that we can send these
events back to the server using the
WebSockets so I'm gonna do that right
now
[Music]
to tell you when the arguments minute is
served girls we're fighting for days
stuck in a face I think we're losing the
reason
[Music]
all right cool so here we go now every
time I press a play it's it sends it to
the server as you can see it press play
every time I press pause
it says pause pause play pause play
pause play so as you can see when I
click the progress bar I get the number
basically this is like how many minutes
or how many seconds into the video I'm
clicking - so if it's at the beginning
it's like zero and then if I click at
the end it's like 47 so 47 seconds
alright there you go so now the player
is connected to the server so that's
cool so I'm done for now I'm not gonna
do anything more because it's already
been 5 10 minutes so I hope you liked
that and I'm gonna continue doing this
on each vlog you know maybe whenever I
want to code and stuff hope you like
this video if you enjoyed it don't
forget to smash that like button and
also subscribe and press the bell
notification so thanks
[Music]
nothing